et voilà ce jour est arrivé on commence
enfin notre série de vidéos sur l'union
européenne
alors oui si parfois l'organisation des
institutions françaises ne semblent pas
toujours simple à comprendre celle de
l'union européenne
à côté c'est carrément le chaos les noms
se ressemblent on confond tout certaines
institutions sont répartis à plusieurs
endroits et certaines qui n'ont aucun
rapport sont au même endroit bref c'est
compliqué mais ne fuyez pas on va y
aller tranquillement et sa valve pour
cette première vidéo sur le sujet on va
commencer par remplacer chute
institutions de l'union européenne dans
son contexte
l'union européenne est une organisation
supranationale spécial et unique en son
genre
il n'y a pas de président ni
gouvernement ni de premier ministre de
l'union européenne il y en tout cette
institution 2 millions européennes qui
sont séparés en plusieurs rôles pour
commencer le centre de décision de
l'union européenne c'est le conseil
européen attention il ne faut pas le
confondre avec le conseil de l'europe
qui lui est totalement indépendant de
l'union européenne le conseil européen
réuni les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 28 états membres lors
des réunions les présidents fixe les
orientations générales et fixe les
priorités politiques de l'union
européenne ensuite du côté législatif et
exécutif
on retrouve la commission européenne qui
définit des propositions de textes
législatifs dans l'intérêt commun de
tous les européens sur la base des
priorités définies par le conseil
européen
donc comme on vient de le dire par les
chefs d'état des pays membres
elle est composée d'un commissaire par
état membre qui ne représente pas son
état mais représente en théorie
l'intérêt général de l'union européenne
les textes rédigés par la commission
européenne sont ensuite débattu modifié
et votée au parlement européen qui est
composé de 7 51 députés se sont eux qui
sont censés représenter les citoyens
européens ils voient que les loin en
fonction de leurs idées et de leurs
affinités politiques et ce sont les
seuls représentants de l'union
européenne choisit directement par les
citoyens européens à travers le suffrage
universel direct pour être adopté un
texte européen doit également être
débattues et votées par les ministres de
l'union européenne ses ministres réunis
au fonction du sujet au sein du conseil
de l'union européenne
aussi appelée plus simplement le conseil
qui n'est toujours pas la même chose que
le conseil de l'europe neagle conseil
européen comme en france où les lois
doivent être adopté par le sénat et par
l'assemblée nationale dans les mêmes
termes
les textes européens doivent être voté
dans les mêmes termes par le parlement
européen donc par les gens que vous avez
élu et par le conseil de l'union
européenne donc par les ministres de
lieux c'est ensuite la commission
européenne qui va vérifier la bonne
exécution des textes par tous les états
membres non qu'on a fait le tour des
institutions législatives et exécutives
parlons institutions juridictionnelles
de l'union européenne
c'est la cour de justice de l'union
européenne qui est composé de 28 jugent
et huit avocats
elle vérifie que l'ensemble des pays
respectent les textes votés
enfin il y a deux institutions
financières qui sont la cour des comptes
européenne qui contrôle les finances de
l'union européenne et la banque centrale
européenne qui gère la monnaie unique
assure la stabilité des prix et mène la
politique économique et monétaire de
l'union européenne et sinon on vous a
parlé du conseil de l'europe
celui-là est complètement indépendant de
l'union européenne mais je me permets
d'en parler quand même ici parce qu'il
est très fréquent de confondre surtout
qu'il est basé à strasbourg juste à côté
des institutions de l'union européenne
du coup le conseil de l'europe c'est
d'une organisation indépendante qui
regroupe 47 états contre 28 pour l'union
européenne et 820 millions d'habitants
contre 512 pour l'union européenne le
conseil de l'europe oeuvre pour la
protection des droits de l'homme et pour
le renforcement de la démocratie
et voilà cette vidéo est finie j'espère
que vous aurez bien compris la
différence entre les sept institutions
européennes et que vous ne confondrait
plus les différents conseils présents en
europe
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à nous suivre sur nos
réseaux sociaux et à bientôt